regardez la télé transparente de LG
c'est du olyte D pour transparent alors
ce sera pas forcément pour tout le monde
vous allez pas forcément mettre une
dalle transparente chez vous mais on
peut imaginer plein d'usages notamment
pour les professionnels peut-être dans
différents endroits voyez avec un
élément central qui vient monter et qui
la rend opaque donc on pourra venir
regarder la télé très facilement et si
on a besoin de l'ouvrir pour avoir une
transparence j'en sais rien pour donner
un effet aquarium peut-être dans un
intérieur pour pouvoir se retrouver avec
une vision à travers je trouve ça génial
parce que LG innove énormément on a
connu les écrans enroulables les écrans
également des moniteurs qui viennent
avoir une sur le côté en fait c'est la
même technologie c'est la même base de
la même idée que l'écran enroulable que
vous aviez vous saviez l'écran qui
sortait d'un élément central et qui
rentrait sauf que là au lieu que ce soit
une dalle qui sorte et qui rentre ça va
être un goût j'imagine de tissu assez
épais totalement opaque pour venir
bloquer la lumière qui va rentrer et qui
va sortir on se parle donc d'une
technologie c'est le OLED timide
transparent bravo LG je trouve ça super
et une fois de plus ça ouvre des usages
ça ouvre des perspectives et ça me fait
rêver parce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous pourriez imaginer avoir ça à la
maison oui ou pas dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires